BUT CAN'T AFFORD
THE LEGAL EXPENSES?
- HI, I'M RON FUNCHES.
JUST TO BE CLEAR,
I AM A PUBLIC DEFENDER.
I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
"WHY DOES A PUBLIC DEFENDER
NEED A COMMERCIAL?"
THE BAD NEWS IS
YOU'RE GOING TO BE CONVICTED.
- GUILTY!
- WE TRIED.
AND IF I'M RANDOMLY SELECTED
TO BE YOUR LAWYER,
I'LL BRING YOU A NICE BOX
OF MY AUNT SANDI'S
PECAN SANDIES.
[cell phone rings]
GUESS MY WORK'S NEVER DONE.
I HAVE TO GO MEET
WITH A NEW CLIENT.
OR SHOULD I SAY FRIEND?
- MY WIFE IS DEAD.
I'VE LOST ALL MY MONEY.
I CAN NO LONGER AFFORD
MY HIGH-POWERED ATTORNEY,
AND EVERYONE'S ABANDONED ME--
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE.
- PECAN SANDIE?
- I'M MORE OF A MINT
MILANO MAN MYSELF, BUT--
- SO YOU KILLED YOUR WIFE?
- I NEVER LAID A HAND
ON MY WIFE,
EXCEPT ON OCCASIONAL
SPECIAL EVENINGS.
- [laughs]
- [chuckles weakly]
IT FEELS REALLY GOOD
TO LAUGH.
- YOU LOOK LIKE A HIGHLIGHTER.
- AND YOU LOOK LIKE A HAIRY
CHOCOLATE GUMMI BEAR.
- [laughs]
- I GOTTA TELL YOU,
MR. FUNCHES,
WE'RE GONNA LAUGH ALL THE WAY
TO NOT GOING TO JAIL.
- EVEN THOUGH YOU'RE NOT GUILTY,
I'M GONNA TAKE THE CASE.
- DO YOU HAVE A CHOICE IN THAT?
- NO.
- 'CAUSE YOU'RE A PUBLIC
DEFENDER.
- YEAH.
- DR. ARMOND, PLEASE RISE.
YOU STAND HERE ACCUSED
OF MURDER IN THE SECOND DEGREE.
HOW DO YOU PLEAD?
- GUILTY...
OF LOVING MY WIFE.
- [laughs]
[upbeat wrap-up music]